We can start this problem by distributing the 4. We want to clear our grouping.
So I get 4x plus 8 on the left. I want to isolate the variable on one side of
the inequality sign. I'm going to choose to subtract 4x. I made this decision so
I could keep my variable positive. I know when I subtract 4x here, I'll wind up
with positive 2x. So, positive 8 is less than or equal to 2x minus 8. Next, I
add 8 to both sides to isolate my 2x. So I have 16 is less than or equal to 2x.
Finally, I divide both sides by 2, the coefficient in front of x. So I have 8 is
less than or equal to x, which is really the same thing as x greater than or
equal to 8. So I use a bracketed 8, and then I want any numbers greater than 8,
so up to positive infinity. This would be the interval notation.